this video was sponsored by Muslim
Master inshah to be with confidence in
speak brother sister confidence is very
important confidence was one of the
things that led me to Islam not my own
confidence but the confidence of Zak
ahed the confidence that he had in his
religion made me realize why is he so
sure about what he speaking and he made
me listen to him attentively so guys
when it comes the confidence and how to
speak you need this in marriage work
colleagues friends giving da so BR
sisters many diet have also taking this
course in please check in the link below
let's get straight to the video Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
there was a video circulating online
about a woman um doing TA in meca in
front of the Caba and she starts to
scream and shout now nobody knows what
this means but there's quite a few
possibilities there's a big Superstition
a big um rumor that's going around which
is not true that's been going around
from a long long time ago we're going to
address that in but let's just deal with
this Superstition here is the video clip
of this lady bugging out in front of uh
the CA and let's see what is going on
[Music]
as you wor out for yourself this man we
don't know if he Maham or not but in
this instance I don't know the ruling on
um an individual doing r i mean I mean
she hasn't got her Mah around which
there's an opin about traveling there
with M that's a different story but um
Can someone else do Ria on you I mean if
your m is not there and you're bugging
out in that way I mean it's good if it's
um another woman but that's a different
topic I wish is not here about the mam
issue the issue is that there has been a
story going around circulating from
a couple of hundred years ago if I'm not
mistaken that um there was a woman who
traveled to Mecca and she was involved
in she used to do black magic or The
Story Goes uh in a nutshell is that um
she used to if I'm not mistaken she used
to actually I don't know if this a
couple hundred years ago she used to um
do and she used to do it in a way where
she used to work in hospital and in the
hospitals she used to get the s in a TA
and put it in the dead bodies in the
mouth and Stitch the lips up yeah so she
would do this to multiple bodies yeah so
not many people knew imagine your loved
one who's deceased lips sealed up but
there's inside the mouth so this is what
she used to do and apparently that she
traveled to Mecca I'm not talking about
this lady by the way I'm not talking
about this lady I'm talking in the video
I'm talking about this story that
connects to the story of uh which I'm
about to tell you the the Superstition
this um this false notion that she went
to Mecca and she said that she couldn't
see she couldn't see the ca she she was
doing ta
clockwise because usually we do T
anticlockwise so she was doing it
clockwise so when they stopped and said
what are you doing they said she said I
don't know I I cannot see the Caba so
some people took from this that because
of the the severe that she done in that
matter if I'm not mistaken the story
that this caused her to not say the Caba
is this true no I mean the story I mean
this could happen however to say that
there is evidence there is no evidence
from the Quan and or the or anywhere
that if somebody's involved in or magic
or whatever for that matter they will
not see the ca why the scholars use the
evidence that the mus were doing on
another level I mean that is a form
of but they were doing outright idolatry
and they could see the ca clearly so
there is no evidence from the Quran or
that tells us that anyone that involves
in or Maes or whatever is for that
matter when you go to the ca you can't
see the ca it's there's no uh grounding
in Islam for that matter however can it
be that this lady was possessed can be
can it be that she committed a major sin
and she saw something I don't know it
can be or it can be that she's not
mentally well it can be a mental mental
disorder it can be a mental illness so
we as Muslims we love to jump to
automatically you tripped over somebody
done evil eye and black magic on yeah
somebody's got nothing better to do they
doing evil eye on you black magic on you
so you can trip up now this does this
mean that it cannot be an evil that
could cause you to trip up yes the
problem is that we go straight to
Superstition straight to it's it's black
magic it's evil eye it's it can be but
don't label everything that you know
don't always blame the Shan for your
faults you know oh I committed a sin oh
I understand Shan gives you was take
some accountability you know blame
yourself sometimes you know actually
it's me my notan you for everything so I
would say inshah that we need to
understand this phenomena and it's it's
a big reality to us cuz we know people I
know people who have gone to the Caba
and said I didn't feel anything now now
my occurrence my instance I'll be honest
with you like I've been to Mecca a
couple of times and certain times when
I've been I can remember about two years
ago or something that I went my
experience was totally different
genuinely I felt more close why it can
be that there was sins that I was
committing that had a barrier it can
genuinely be that that when you get
close to Allah not that I'm saying I am
any closer but when you try your best to
get close to Allah you get rid of those
sins Allah opens the Delight of the
Quran to you Allah opens the sweetness
of IM for you I genuinely believe this
the more you commit lessons the more you
work on something that is a big fitner
for you whatever it is and you're trying
your best the more Allah makes you taste
the sweetness of IM this is a h brothers
and sisters so what I'm going to say is
may Allah give sh to the sister if it's
a r
issue obviously could do on if it's a
mental illness issue may Allah subh give
sh but there is no basis or substance of
she couldn't see the CA and she was look
listen this Superstition don't bring
Superstition to Islam okay we have the
Quran and the Sunnah that tells us
clearly and other than that brother and
sisters protect yourself with your in
the mornings and in the evenings
inshallah if you've missed it please
don't miss it inshallah for that matter
so brothers and sisters inshallah do you
protect you from all this stuff and
physical harms unless what Allah subhana
wa tala will it to be that's all I have
to say inah may Allah subhana bless and
protect you guys do your Salah give the
rights of Allah subhana tala be obedient
to your parents and morning and evening
till next time